okay uh welcome
kia ora
um to the
august meeting of the
um
community strategy committee
um
we've got a few around the table today
which is good to see and we're
starting to get back into some normalcy
so or what the new normal is
uh i do have one apology here from uh
councillor bulger is there any other
apologies
on the floor
i'll just have something to move that
those apologies are accepted uh
councillor dixon and secretary uh
expression
uh mayor hicks
all those in favor
thank you
okay we've got a reasonably interesting
agenda this afternoon with a number of
different reports and uh some of them
are obviously updates and continuation
of some of our good projects that are
happening around
around town um and around the community
um and uh
along with some to make some decisions
around on where we were going to so
um
first item on the agenda today is
obviously gemma down down the back there
if she wants to come up jimmy you can
use one of the microphones so that
i'm sure nick will show you how it works
so
um
yeah if i'll get um
get the community strategy manager to
uh obviously active southland and their
annual report
okay the purpose of the report that's in
front of you is the year ending 30th of
june 2022 because you'll remember the
council has a contract for service
through to june
2024 active southland and it's thirty
thousand dollars per annum and so
gemma's here to give us an overview of
all the work they've been doing in the
district
um hi everybody nice to see you all
again my name is gemma o'neill i'm the
eastern active coordinator for active
southland
um
maybe a few faces i haven't seen since
we've rebranded so you may know us
previously as sport southland
just a year gone by now where we've been
active southland which um was based
around being a bit of representation of
the work we do
throughout the community not that
sport's not important to us it very much
still is but it just encompassed more of
our
initiatives
um
thank you for having me today uh firstly
i'd just like to apologize on behalf of
jess stormagan our current interim ce um
she couldn't be here today um
but thank you again from her for
allowing us to come and have a chat and
our continued
work we do together in the community
between active south and the gore
district council which we are hugely
appreciative of
um
as you can see from the
length of the report sorry about the
reading content there people um we
um it's not just
myself and my role that works into the
gore and eastern region
we have a huge contribution um from all
of our teams that we have
most of the rest of them based out of
our invercargill office but um it's a
it's an organization-wide contribution
to what happens out here across our
different teams our different contract
areas
and so this report is is highlighting
that that mahi that comes our way we're
very proud to be able to represent uh
and do work for the eastern southland
community um and we hope to carry on
with all this long into the future
um
20 odd pages of
uh stuff as i said to the team when we
submitted this last week it's it's work
that's not to be sniffed at we've done
an amazing amount for our community
across a wide scope from health to
sports to schools
and just about everything in between and
yeah we've
really enjoyed it and our highlights
include um
things like our gorez
promotion we've done in conjunction with
stakeholders with you guys through
the parks and recreation team helping
promote local open spaces
activating sites um
but we're trying to carry on in that
space and being as reactive to our
community as we can in terms of what
we're doing on the ground out here as
well so where we can we take on as much
insight and information from our
community members in terms of planning
what our next steps are so for example
the gorillas project commented on in
here
our next iteration will come in the next
set of school holidays based off
feedback we got from the last lot so
over 100 respondents came through
for the activation we did in the green
space of the town about here in the
april school holidays
um so we've taken on boards that the
people were looking for
free family-friendly activities that
they could do in their own time
at their own pace um
you know learning about new places and
seeing new things so um that's what we
intend to carry on within the october
school holidays we do also intend to
move that out more regionally regionally
in eastern even though we've used the
hashtag gorez
um we will continue using that we've had
a lot of feedback that's become a
recognizable thing locally but we do
intend to take things to these smaller
communities and and using the same
process of talking with the locals as we
go and planning things that suit them
what they want how they want it where
they want it when they want it that kind
of activity
so that's sort of us in a nutshell um if
there's any questions from the report
please don't hesitate to sing out um and
same with down the line if anyone's got
anything they want to discuss as we
carry on um through the year please
we're always got an open door down there
at the stadium so
always keep in touch
yes um
thank you gemma
um probably one of the comments you've
actually addressed what i've what i was
going to say right at the start there
that there has been a lot of activity
there and there's a lot of information
and a lot of um
a lot of input going across the
community um
probably one of the questions i'd
probably have is just in regard to the
change since we've we've obviously had
an interesting couple of years with the
younger and the youth and school
um are we noticing that across some of
the activities and and people coming
into them or
whether there has been a change in
attitude and
definition
yep um
we're getting a lot of feedback through
schools through sports um through
community groups through social services
around the fact that people were um they
either broke a habit that they might
have been into and and going back to
whatever they're doing was hard or the
options available for them to go back to
post covered was um restricted or
changed and not what they might have
been looking for so one of the things we
try to do in that insights and locally
led approaches around working with those
provision groups around
creating opportunities that are
based solely off what people want taking
on board their participant view and and
putting that forward in in what they
promote to the community or what they
have on offer so that's something we
continue working on um this day and age
the old cookie cutter we've always done
it that way approach doesn't fit
especially in the youth in the ragataki
teenage space anymore and so trying to
work on ways to
have opportunities for people to
participate in a way that suits them um
is where we're really focusing on with
especially with that age group at the
moment okay
thanks for that um open it up to the
counsellor's
question
nick
you just want to say yeah thanks for the
great report it was a good read um
you've certainly made a lot of key um
relationships with um a lot of the
schools and everything it's quite neat
driving past the schools and see
everyone out activating
and all that
probably from my point of view the only
thing that i
would probably may be put more emphasis
on is how our tennis clubs
can we get more people joining up to
them is sort of yeah is my next step
from the future
yeah but other than that yeah great
report was a good read thank you thank
you
thank you um
councillor macphail um
yeah that's good report gemma and
obviously you've been all working very
very hard um i just wondered are there
any outstanding issues with the youth in
the area that
facilities that they may need and
what would you see as an area
overall that you'd like to see so where
you'd like to be working and putting
some resources into i think in that
rangatahi space in that teenage age
space a lot of it's not necessarily
around facilities but around
participation structures um
struggling to get um
for various reasons a lot of barriers in
a way but trying to get people to commit
to the original we'll have this many
weeks it'll cost you this much you'll do
this many games it'll be this that as
we've always been it's just it's really
getting hard for whanau to commit to
these days and if we can work with those
providers whether it be the facility or
the activity itself around making sure
that um those
participation structures are more
aligned to what the user is looking for
then naturally that should increase uh
participation in those groups so whether
that's a sport for us they're sort of
the three avenue sport active rick and
play
they are across all of the age groups so
we're trying to work in those three
areas with local groups around what that
might look like going forward you would
have seen mentioned in the report of our
chumanoa act of
fund so we have funds available that we
administer on behalf of sport nz for
eligible groups to apply for and it's
it's it's have a go money it's it's um
in a way for people to give these things
a go without having a risk
attached to yeah so if anything comes
from that whatever learning's good bad
or otherwise
it's that they can obviously get
involved in that give it a go and learn
from it one way or the other
i think particularly that rangatahi
space is quite big for us we've had done
a lot of work
individually with recently myself
menzies saint peters and gohai
so working in with those kids in in
and that's i think nailed it they're
working with the children yes you've got
to bring the adults along the journey
but working with those children that's
particularly what we'll go forward with
in in the future if one of the things
we'll go forward with in the future
that's a priority yeah they are the
group that are um
increasingly dropping out of sport and
recreation in that age space yeah yeah i
think that's really important it's good
to hear thank you thank you
dennis
thank you mr chair um it's a great
report that you have you may and my
question is i know that a lot of young
people are really into technology at the
moment so how do you combine
technology maybe with getting children
active is there a secret to that
well that's that's one way to crack i
think and i think it's not it's not just
our organization that's across the board
the the technology world cannot be um
excluded anymore we can't look at it as
a negative we've got to use it for its
positives and whether that fits into
play active recreation or sport as i
said we've got all learned to work
together for us to learn more about it
and then work with those youth around
how we can apply it in those settings to
make it a more positive experience and
use use it as a benefit not as a barrier
any further
questions
thank you mr chair it's not actually a
question but further to councillor
dixon's comment um
excuse me um i know that one of the
groups locally and you probably know
them too that do a lot of their online
gaming stuff they actually have a sport
component where they break down and then
they
have an active part to it is that
somewhere you see that um it might be an
opportunity to do the same sort of thing
absolutely it's one of those things
where like i said we have to go we have
to roll with these things if that's part
of what the youth are looking for to get
them active whatever way that looks like
we have to we have to be able to be um
react to that scenario and go forward
with it and if we can combine them and
it brings more people on board whatever
it needs to do we'll make it we'll we'll
do our best to make sure that that's an
appropriate way to go with these guys
absolutely yeah great thanks
thanks mr chair just a couple of
comments gemma
thank you very much for the work that
you're doing here and you know active
south and often flies beneath the radar
and it's not until you see it in written
form here you realize just
the
length and breadth of of the activity
you have here it's fantastic so so well
done just in terms of what's happening
at escort school in the active schools
program
so i get my understanding is the next
step is getting more funding is that
right yep so
can we do anything to help that i mean
don't ask us for money but can we help
you ask other people for money yeah as
you guys have been an integral
stakeholder into that process with the
neighborhood place system in escort and
so
absolutely anything you guys can and
concord you contribute from
putting us on to the right people
backing
what we're going for what the guys are
going forward for whether it be through
wendy at the school or through the team
internally um we'll of course
gratefully take that on board so
that is the current um
status they're looking for
funders to come on board and any way we
can remove any barriers to get those
projects moving forward is going to be
warmly welcomed
so i guess the connection
um from you guys to us is through keith
is it yes currently yep okay
no well done thank you
the other questions from
floor
if we just have one uh someone move that
that report has received uh
councillor reed and sentence
councillor phillips
all those in favor
thank you gemma thank you keep up the
good work appreciate it thank you very
much everyone
okay yep
matter on the agenda is with our really
living coordinator kylie's here so
um quite topical really
because we've um
had just about weekly around the
countryside various issues happening in
the emergency management
and uh also topical because we've had
environment south here a couple of weeks
ago telling us that we've got some
issues with our flood banks so
um yeah
we'll leave new hands to brief us
so
in our original action plan for
the two years 2021-23
and
we decided that emergency management
would be something that needs locked at
for the older community
um and exactly it like seeing the floods
in the last few weeks west coast being
hit three times four times now a week
whatever we're up to um just being aware
that these things are happening more
frequent and the alpine fault is also
um
predicted to go in the next wee while so
it's science
so it's just about being prepared so
lots of older people i talk to
aren't prepared
um
haven't got water rely on electricity
which is probably likely to be cut off
with a storm earthquake and flooding
area three main ones in goa so we've
worked with emerge i've been working
with emergency management southland
along
that
the importance of heating or something
to heat
either heat your home or heat your food
if there's no power lots of people
without fires
and things so talking to older people
about those things
and
and the new reliance on carers cleaners
and meals on wheels so older people will
be encouraged to stay in their homes
longer
which is
i guess causing a different issue for
emergency management if they're in their
homes and need a carer coming in six
times a day
i think there's some people getting it
that many times a day have you had your
meds have you eaten have you
shower and
food
yep so that rather do that than
rest time so it's a new
a new way of thinking and we're just
working through that and met with the
dhb older persons
manager
um last week so
yeah but that's the way the system's
moving to um
so about emergency management for these
people is going to be quite critical and
not relying on meals on wheels
potentially not getting to these people
also having options or having them
prepared as well
um medication and repeats and things
like that
came up as important
just going through
so this morning
very conveniently this is our draft
guide sonia hasn't even seen it i
haven't been to work today but it will
look maybe something like this um
a booklet specifically designed for
older people to start thinking about
preparedness
um
covering things like
um
medications having them on board what
you need in your getaway packs and in
your home
medications pets reminding because that
was one of the things a lot of older
people couldn't take pets with them
so
that's came up as a section
as well
so it's just hopefully all included
we're trying to cut it down but yeah
we'll
review it so there's the booklet hoping
to do some first aid courses for older
people so just getting them underway so
that won't be a qualification it will
just be sitting there learning about the
pre-hospital
type admission or anything that might
relate to them in just like a two three
hour block
um and i've talked to a few older people
and they said well i won't be able to do
cpr and i was like
it would be good if you came and learned
how to talk someone else through it um
and things like that so it's a different
aspect looking at how older people can
do first aid so hopefully we'll have our
first course before christmas and
depending how we go a couple next year
emergency management southland's going
to be speaking to some different groups
older people groups on being prepared in
the hazards
and then hopefully i'm going to do a
campaign leading up to christmas um
for the hard to buy for people on giving
them emergency management preparedness
gear from water to maybe a guest cooker
i bought my grandma one
all ready to
have at her house
just to be prepared so just a different
campaign i guess to work on
and as well as that they have clued up
kids for
younger people so cleared up kids has
fire ambulance police all the services
um there to talk to
younger people so we're looking to um
doing something around that for seniors
that fit more into
there also
and then we'll be visiting rest homes
and just
working with them on plans
hopefully covered everything
um thanks kylie i do say there'll be a
few
questions here just um from uh
a query in regard to obviously
it is
within the health service and and older
age people now they are leaving them in
the at home and trying to provide
services there those lists of those
people that are getting those services
that obviously incorporated
in here somewhere so that if we do shut
the town down for a period of days that
we actually
get them sent to us and part of that
emergency management response
because there's different as you say
some can have can have three to four to
five visits a day and some
every couple of days so yeah um
that obviously formals part of that
basis yeah we have talked about as well
as having it on the ground doing
something at the
what's the operation center
eoc center at that level as well having
some paperwork in there and how we're
going to link
and with those healthcare dhb
workers to get their information at
their time yeah yeah so yeah there's
that aspect
in working with medical centers
because
it's a double-sided issue with the fact
that you've got the
not only then when they become isolated
it's also the workers that are coming in
yeah obviously have the situational
confusion or the the change in what's
going on and can't service them so yeah
um
and the other one is obviously the gas
cookers well most
town families have got gas cookers and
their garages and they're called
barbecues so lots of older people don't
have barbecues because they know that
their neighbours may have them or yeah
yeah someone could have that so
neighborhood stuff is probably part of
the support network so but um no uh
interesting and it is very topical um
we're seeing things just about every
week now where um whether it slips
floods
winds um you name it it's there so uh
i'll open it up to the floor for um
bronwyn
it is topical and i think it's really
important and the one thing that the
seniors in our area are presumably like
that throughout the country they're used
to being very independent and they try
hard to keep that independence there but
i also know that when there's been
issues and they've had to ring for the
ambulance things like that it's quite
often after the event and
and i think maybe in part of that
booklet or part of those
community meetings and things that
you're going to have we need to reassure
them that it's actually okay to actually
ask for help
and whether that be through their
emergency buttons or picking up the
phone and do they have something
like a 1-1 call on as an emergency on
their phones as well i don't know but i
just think that's the reassurance for
them yeah no you're not putting this out
please run you're putting us to more
trouble if you don't um
yeah we did have that in one of the
first versions i can't remember if it's
in this version
but yeah the older people seem to
there's people that need more help than
me but actually they're going down but
there is a big going to be a bit of work
done by dhb i believe on the um
pre-hospital admission how they can help
with that stuff to reduce hospital
admissions
it's it's really good to see that this
is all being put in place i think it's
quite reassuring so yeah great
dennis thank you mr chair um
good overview kylie i'm just wondering
um you were doing computer courses for
older people which could be quite
important for them as well at this time
do you are you going to continue with
those or um rape's still got the
contract so they're doing a couple more
now and i believe the library
had the contract as well but it never
really started so in the new building it
might be something something we can talk
about again and i also think that
neighbourhood watch could play a big
part in this just to keep an eye on
they've got their own section
yeah so i've been linking in with kelly
and they can work together on that
yes great i agree with what bronwyn's
saying too they
um they do elderly people do like to be
independent i know i run a few people
during covert and they're saying well
you didn't bother about
older people before why your ringing is
now sort of thing so
i think
it is important that we keep their
independence but also encourage them to
seek help when needed
tracy kylie just a quick question you
get any sense of the numbers of people
that are getting multiple visits per day
by by nurses or medicals don't know
i think
tracy we could actually get that
information if we if we wanted
when i met with um
sharon adler on friday we talked about
data and what was available
so i think over the next week while
we'll be collating some of that to get a
better perspective
but one of the big challenges with that
and gore at the moment is lack of staff
to actually service and talking with
sharon
like
almost on a daily basis families are
getting phone calls to say
you know we care can't come because of
sickness and you know the same issues
that are happening in businesses
and it's fine if you have some family in
gore but it's not fine for those
people that don't and there is
significant numbers that don't have
family here
so
there's a whole raft of issues in that
space and we just need to quietly keep
working through it
um
and i guess with the locality network
starting to get established some of
those things are going to be
up for discussion
and how we go forward but we have sharon
actually coming to go for
international older person day as a
speaker and her and carl will be
speaking so
that's going to be a real opportunity
to i guess socialize some conversation
with older people around a raft of
issues that will work on into the future
yeah
thanks ann um you know yeah i think it
just
you raise a whole lot of good points
there but in terms of getting a sense of
the the number of people we're dealing
with here will be really helpful as
we're doing our civil defense planning
going forward
and also you mentioned the localities
network and i think that's it's a pretty
important
change and strategy for for any
community and it's going to be
particularly so for us and i think as a
community strategy committee it would be
really good to get someone
and someone like stuart barson who's
right in the middle of that to come and
present to the community strategy
committee at some point in time
no some um good points here tracy thank
you
sorry just another query
i feel like we're probably
thinking more of the residents in town
i'm presuming that matara and waikaka
residents
will be
included in all of this and also in
those on the periphery of those towns
too there's a lot of people who are
still in their own homes but out of town
and not connected as much so
there may be need more work needed
to integrate them into all of those
different parts of that program yeah so
um
just on that
note with neighborhood support we've
been having some discussions about
a piece of work that we would do in our
rural communities and how we connect
with them because they're quite key
and and other
in most other parts of the country
neighborhood support is a function
within council and in our case it isn't
so it's actually really important that
we work really closely with them and
police so we are in the middle of some
discussions and we will be having some
conversations with
the older person
of our community
i guess and we've definitely got rural
on the on the radar there
and i know when you talk to the two care
agents sees that they
certainly can give us the numbers in our
spaces that they're going to on a daily
basis
okay any further questions or discussion
right thanks kylie that's obviously
a good update and obviously proceeding
in a good direction um
hopefully sooner rather than later that
it hits the ground and hopefully it
doesn't have to be
put into
action too soon so but um as you say
it's sort of not if but when so
um if i just have someone move to
receive that
councillor and segment councillor dixon
all those in favor
thank you
move on to our second item which is
being
presented by
kylie again in relation to the review of
the
80s years
and i have a parking permit so if you'd
like to give us a rundown on that
see how we're doing
implemented the 80 plus parking permit
in october last year
202 people have received the parking
permit
providing meter spaces
free parking in the meted spaces the
older members of the community
we had amazing feedback from all the
over 80s um
even receiving a handwritten letter by
one older lady
thanking us so much
for it and how much she appreciated it
no name for coins how marvelous it was
and no fret if you can
caught in a shop too long marvelous we
got two marvelous um so i did a random
survey of 17 older people that have the
pyramid um
and had all positive responses
from them
um
on average
10
older people use permit two or more
times a week
three used it weekly three used it
fortnightly and one used it not very
often
a gentleman that only goes to the
supermarket he told me
100 were grateful and appreciated the
free parking and found it useful
some comments that came up
it's out of this world amazing we love
it it's we're very grateful for free
parking
it's really good very generous to the
council
free parking is wonderful very good it's
very nice for us to have it
really great convenient
i'm not a good walker came up quite a
few times around then um
stating older people staying there
um the process of applying for the
parking permit was easy um everyone said
and couldn't suggest any changes
to that process
they found it useful
because of poor balance or couldn't
stand for long periods of time so just
being able to get out of the car and go
to the shops
um
the lack of change in society now
but quite quite a few are quick to say
it's not that i can't afford it type
worry that we're
judging as we're saying it um
convenient
well
some that were more able had parked in
new world or non-mated
parks and they enjoyed being able to
park closer to the shops
um
and that they weren't as restricted as
much of how many coins they had
and yeah they didn't see any changes
needed
and that
um when asked what else could council do
for you
it wasn't quite worded like that but
um
one suggested that the parking could um
if it could be reciprocal with
invercargills free over 1880 parking
and they found the parking meter
attendant helpful when um
applying for permits on the street i
know
um
so most didn't have any other
things for council to do um i had we
need to be thankful for what we have
don't molly cuddle older people
make it um
keep making them carry on
um
free dump charges came up better
footpaths
remove planters on oak street you'll be
a few happy at the moment
and lower rates of course um
and some people originally suggested um
lowering the age to 65 or 70 for free
parking but we feel
that 80 is a good age to keep it at
um
and the revenue lost um is hard to
determine with covert and other factors
in the last
10 months i think
oh no it was yes
um so there was a change there from 71
to 52 but um i guess other things could
have affected that as well as less parks
on eric street and
different things as well so
okay um
thanks carly for the update uh
there's obviously a couple of things in
there i'm not sure about the lower rates
i think it was probably people under 80s
would like that as well
so and i think we have got rid of the
plants on eric street now so we've got a
couple of wins there
um but yeah in regards to that indica or
the reciprocal agreement so we will
where can we go with that um is there
anything we can work on i can
essentially um communicate with them and
ask once i guess new councils and it
will be something
because we would offer it back the other
way for all the invocable shoppers
coming to course
yeah
encouraging to come up so i think that
would be something to pursue
look i think
you look at the commentary here it was a
good a good move to get it through and
we've done well so but i'll open it up
to the floor for
questions or commentary
clintus
thank you mr chair um there's no real
discussion in my view about this i think
it's a great initiative and we should
keep
keep on doing this the 80 year olds are
very pleased with it
sorry i'm happy to remove to remove to
move the report um it's a good report
and it's nice to think that we're
actually doing something positive
and getting a plus a bit of tick
thanks kyle
um someone liked the second that or
further commentary or second
councillor grant all those in favor
carried thank you and uh thanks kylie
for the effort
interesting times and uh yeah keep up
the good work
okay
uh
we move on to item four um closing the
gaps and i see we have mark here welcome
mark
it's good to see you
um
and i'll let you have the floor along
with them and
who want to start what do you guys want
to start so
um obviously a report to june
afternoon everyone and so the report
submitted gives you an overview of the
work carried out by closing the gap
scheme um in the last financial year to
30th of june
um so we've had yet another really
successful year with closing the gaps
we are provided with funding to support
50 placements in the local district and
we managed to fund 51 placements
and we also supported supported a
further 10 placements
of those 51 27 which is a very large
number we're actually supportive of
apprenticeships in the area
um from 24 different companies
and five of those five more are actually
pending registration as well so that's a
really large number
um we do have a small number of people
leaving their positions unfortunately
but that's understandable in such an
employee bias market at the moment and
what we do as part of our pastoral care
processes
and talk to those employees to determine
why they're leaving how we can support
the business moving forward and possibly
support those employees as well to find
further work
[Music]
so
we have enabled local businesses to
support youth
and to
provide training to
purchase equipment such as tools etc
and that's facilitated the retention of
needs in the area as a result
and we've been able to reinforce and
establish connections with the local
business
and commun business community
and a lot of good will has been created
as a result so much so that now we have
so many of our referrals happening
through the sharing of the scheme with
other businesses by those that are
already involved
um we have a closing the gaps website
which as of yesterday um was advertising
78 positions in the school district so
still quite a large number
um
we disseminate information to uh 64
members
um on a gore um
business network facebook page make them
aware of opportunities and events that
are coming up
and we also use that as a platform to
share information about things like
immigration new zealand criteria such as
the accredited employer work visa and
that was launched recently
and we also provide information during
lockdown periods about covered
restrictions possible msd supports as
well
and something else that we make
businesses aware of which supports
apprentices locally is apprenticeship
boasts which they can use to subsidize
wages in addition to closing the gaps
funding so it's something well worth
pursuing
moving forward this year
um
completion of the gore district business
survey 2022 which we'll hear more about
later on
um has gained information that will
inform a new gore district workforce
plan
including needs of businesses and
insights into the current business
climate within the school district
and the fi the focus will prioritize
engagement with the food and fiber
sector particularly farmers who we're
really striving to engage more and more
with
working more closely with local high
schools and great south in the future to
establish how we can work together to
more effectively deliver outcomes for
youth once they leave school so we were
asked um
at the beginning of the year to provide
numbers of neets
which is basically um youth that are not
in employment education or training and
we were asked by great south to
provide numbers around those
people but we weren't able to do so it's
a very hard thing to do because
high schools no longer have a mandate to
work with those students once they leave
school necessarily unless they
and unless they come under other service
providers it's very hard to track down
those
um people that die outside those
services
but in working with the high schools
more closely we can get a better gauge
of that we can support their transition
into the workplace from school
and we can also look at supporting
students at high school to gain their
driver's license before they leave
school so that they can hit the ground
running
with at least their restricted license
when they leave school and then improve
their employability
and work is currently being carried out
to explore if there's a need to support
local apprentices providing a venue to
network
and work on assignments in addition to
the support that eitos already provide
like bcito in the building sector
and we feel that there's real
potential in this to support those
apprentices so they can come together
over pizza share ideas and that be
supported by visiting ito's as well
thank you
um probably i'd just add that
as of today achieve executives signed
the contract for the next
round um there's some changes in
um
i guess if the criteria is broadened
which will actually help
us because we've had people that have
been coming to us that
weren't within the criteria uh last year
so that's a real positive and we pushed
quite hard to get that criteria changed
so our next step for this year is to get
our employability
person on board in a fixed term contract
so you'll see that happen in the next
few weeks um
yeah so that's sort of where we're at
with the with the going forward but we
were actually really pleased with how
the end result for the year yeah
i suppose the other probably thing i
should comment on is we've had really
good partnerships throughout
southland
so
two years ago that wasn't the case and
we've worked really
hard with likes of the hokanui
um
the
great south msd
so there's some really good partnerships
and we've just partnered with
uh workbridge in the last couple of
months and had a session with farmers
and we had all of the agencies in the
room and there was some really amazing
outcomes from a workforce perspective so
we intend to do that again with some
other sectors
um
so the agricultural sector was actually
one of the hard ones for us to tap into
but we're actually starting to make some
nice inroads in there and being able to
find the gems
where we can actually
help so
that's sort of where we act
for going forward
um thanks ann and thanks mark um
good to see you here in person i'll say
it again because it was good to see your
smiling face
and uh also the fact that that work as
you know fruition
um was coming to fruition and there is
particularly those positions i know it's
one of those things that
um
you know we don't go waving the banner
too much and we actually see it see it
at the end of the day seeing those
results coming through
um just a query in regard to the job
seeker
allowances network what where are we
sitting now like what's the stats
with gore
numbers-wise i know we used to say about
400 and something like it's like it's
less than that yeah it's 3.4 i believe
so about 300 and
they were there about yeah 340.
so for the other thing i should just
mention is that the difference going
into this year is that we will be able
to give up to 6 000 to a business
but three is tagged at a wages level and
three is
um an employability level okay and then
there is some flexibility around the
pastoral care
and other training so it's
it's going to be a little bit more
tricky but um
i think we can work with it and get some
good outcomes for our businesses and
young people
thanks ann and uh before i open it up
obviously there's a there's quite a
connect between this and the next
business survey and and that those good
inroads that are coming with the private
primary sector because you know
everyone's looking for staff and
absolutely you know we are getting those
connections so i'll open it up to the
floor for discussion or commentary
clearness
thank you mr chair um just
reading through the business sector and
seeing that
um what is keeping young people back
from going into farming and one of the
things is the long is isolation there's
a whole lot of things there
how do we change that perception of
of
farming for young people because it's
important i know farmers are
lacking in staff and skilled staff or if
we haven't got young people coming on
it's
going to be difficult
i think that comes under some work that
great south would be looking to do in
terms of educating students
within high schools
and you know
changing those perceptions hopefully so
that they can go and
explore
as as a career path and actual
placements through
possibly gateway
but yeah they need that education first
so
at the meeting that we had with the
farming community and the agencies
there is a body now that actually is
taking young people so at that event
what was really good is
there was a quite a number of students
that were into the agricultural sector
and there is cl there is more defined
pathways
so it's it's working with the schools
and the young people to
to identify what people are interested
in and putting the ideas in front of
them but i think the interesting piece
of work that we did there was when you
go out into a district and you start
talking to the farmers
in the farming community there's a lot
of farmers that do not actually employ
people anymore
and it became really evident when we
were trying to define who those people
are and in talking to different farmers
to say well who do you know that's out
there that employs
and so it's the contract community that
are doing the work on farms
and so it's trying to find the pathways
into those spaces and they can be more
difficult because we have a massive
driver's license issue
and
so you need to have a full license
before you can progress to the other
licenses that are required in those
businesses
so
it's about breaking it down
and then
working on solutions for the different
pieces of the industry
do you feel that that's something that
reek could be involved in is getting
people to that stage where they can get
their heavy traffic license
so
you'll be aware that
i think it was in the budget round the
government has put a significant amount
of money which is coming through from
msd as the agency
and in discussions with msd
in the last two weeks they're still
trying to work out how
that will get delivered on the ground
and we've certainly put a hand up we'd
have already been in discussions with
mpi and
rape because we see reap as the key
provider
with the drive and my life program and
what was really encouraging
to me was msd see that as well
but it's just
there's a gap coming from wellington to
our local communities that we've just
got to wait patiently and it'll work get
worked out
so for us definitely they're in the
equation and
we've
have been having discussions with them
in mpi for
i don't know it's probably about eight
months now but now there's some funding
because that was part of the barrier and
the next piece is actually the work that
we're going to do with the schools and
we have one school that has put their
hand up and said we're happy to pilot
with you and so rip will be part of it
thanks mark and no questions from me
we're just look congratulations on the
work that you're doing i i see the
results
and i hear the the good comments coming
back from from employers of of the
the process that you run and the
relationships that are built through
that so
great stuff well done
thank you
uh
neville thanks mr i just got a question
uh in regards to the driving licence is
the percentage really high is it above
60 70
of the group that have that come to you
without without a license you know
so um just to give you an indication
uh at google high when we serviced them
last year there was two people leaving
year 13 with a full license
so it's a really low number of young
people that are living with full license
and then
i don't have the numbers off the top my
head of what the restricted was
so unless you've got young people that
are highly motivated and they know what
career they're going to go into
and they've got the avenue of good
financial support because that's a
barrier as well as the cost to these
licenses
yeah so so there's definitely a lot of
work to do and it's something that we've
pushed just about in every government
place that we can
because
there has been young people that can't
take jobs because they actually can't
get to work
yeah
having access to a defensive driving
course as well plays a big part in that
if you undertake that it reduces the
time to get your full license by six
months
and if school doesn't provide that
course then
that has that overflow into when they're
looking for work they don't have that
full license quite yet
um
the whole licensing thing is something i
really struggle to get my head around
there does seem to be much less
um
urgency in younger people now to get
their licences and the once was i know
in my um situation by the time i turned
15 um the day i turned 15 i had the
license by 10 o'clock in the morning
and that was just my aim in life was to
get that license but it only happened
because i had parents that were prepared
to teach me to drive for two or three
years before
i was 15 and just educating parents of
the
role that a license has in in somebody's
future is
something that we should be looking at
how we how we can do that
look i understand parents are busy you
know they get home at night and they've
got a lot of things to do so
yeah there's a lot of pressure on
families
thanks for that tracy we won't um ask
what model the car you
you're driving testing
a model a or a model t
but um
actually it was a prince do you know
what a prince was a prince no
i'll tell you later thank you but no i
think you're you are right there is some
it's good there's quite a
quite a rigmarole to go through so
yeah
i was just gonna say mr chairman i'm
very surprised that your compassion and
not digging deeper into the
true motivations of his worship's
parents for getting him as his license
at 15 years of age
right we'll move on from that valid
point
i just have a uh a if there's no further
discussion regarding that uh we'll just
have someone to move that reports
received
uh clearness and uh seconded by uh
council phillips always in favor
okay and now we link some nicely to the
um
the gourd
district business survey report
and i think we have
sort of mark
and
obviously got rebecca and
ken online
hopefully
yep welcome hopefully they can hear us
you're here
okay that's good technology's working
for us
so i'm not sure who wants to lead
you will have met rebecca before because
she has done some other pieces of work
and
kent was a
significant help to us when we did the
first scoping because he actually spoke
to all of the businesses and we've just
completed another 91 interviews so i
asked them to sit in today because i
thought you might have some questions
that's about
their experiences
but the high level of this is
the the importance for us doing the
scoping and closing the gaps is it gives
us a really good insight into where
businesses are at
and also
who actually has jobs out there that we
can place people with
and that was one of the real successes
with our first year of closing the gaps
because we really got a big head start
so that was part of doing this again but
we also wanted to understand how
businesses were actually feeling at this
point in time since we've gone through
covert
so 18 months ago
we had a really positive response
and it's much more
pessimistic i guess at this point in
time
of how people are seeing the next six to
12
months
and we also included the agricultural
sector in this time
[Music]
there might be a bit of
sound coming through from somewhere
yeah
so
probably the things that people are
talking about
is um
the things that are adversely affecting
their businesses supply chain the
staffing and the increase in fuel
so um rebecca and is kendra's any
background that you've got
[Music]
because we've got
maybe you can pop it on binder for becca
and ken should vlog off and log on again
[Music]
yes we can rebecca would you say to be
getting some
feedback
we seem to be picking it up as well
we've got that happening too
we're just trying to work out what that
is
wondering if they should try logging off
and logging on again see what happens
can you give me a baby
can you hear the council
okay just have a test in can you hear us
okay
um so that it at first effects are
really associated to
uh supply chain staffing and the
increasing costs is what people are
telling us
and um the agricultural sector are
really strong around they're struggling
to retain staff and attract staff some
of the contracting spaces are more
positive because they're going to be
bringing in
employees from overseas this year
there's definitely changes in workforce
attitudes that we're picking up in our
district so there's
higher rates of anxiety and wellness
there's a lot more financial pressure
and people are telling us that there's a
change in work ethic as well
but on a more positive note
uh
41 of businesses said that there was an
increase they're looking at potential
expansion uh new products for their
clients and new service offerings
uh i think it was it's really recognized
that there is still a need to be
strengthening a business community
through potential collaboration is what
people have told us
and
um there's still that regulatory um
aspect is coming through that they're
wanting ease of access or ease of
process
uh
around compliance in the regulatory
space
so
i'm gonna leave it there and maybe if
anybody's got any questions
for me or for
no um
thanks ann is is there anything that
you'd like to add there rebecca or kent
around um your information
gathering process or
um
add a wee bit to the commentary of anne
or would you rather us open it up to
some discussion
you're just starting to fade a wee bit
out there ken your microphone have you
is it headphones or you're fading away
yep that's good
yep that's good
any questions okay um
thanks for that kent we'll uh we'll open
it up to
any queries or discussion from the floor
um probably the view you've given us
not necessarily regional but also
national view as well so
um i've identified some
the decline in some of the uh facilities
or
some of the businesses around town i
think most of us would have realized
that the foot traffic and there's a few
more empty parks around town
in the last few months so um i'll open
it up to the floor for any commentary or
questions
really self-explanatory no one wants to
update us
um thank you mr chair
i'm just wondering um what you need
about the businesses thought to
strengthen the community that they
should have more collaboration amongst
the businesses what does that actually
mean
how what do they feel needs to happen
there
the businesses have said that they feel
that um that they need to have more
collaboration between the businesses
that's um to strengthen the business
community so what does that actually
mean
yeah i think i think most of that was
with
regards for their sectors
and and possibly uh people who are
flying local and sort of supporting
locally um
it wasn't really
there was always a bit of an idea of
desperation
getting people from outside the district
like buying their vehicles elsewhere and
things like that
that does upset people a little bit
but
i think
there was a there was it was also said
that they would quite like um
would be more of a place to come in
weekends and you know certain shops
should open up
um
on like a saturday morning
they thought
it was just things like that it was
there was no real sort of
sort of great ideas i think with regards
to the retaliation that they were
they were
sort of a little bit disappointed that
the government wasn't um
i guess from our perspective um
the collaboration
like what we've just done with the
farming community there's been some good
outcomes
uh some of the training opportunities
we're going to be that are going to be
coming through with great south what
we're doing with the m is actually
getting people in the room and sharing
some ideas in stimulanting today so i
had a really good conversation
with marianne weber for the food and
fibre and bernadette hunt around there
and they were really excited about some
collaborations that were setting up in
gore
so i guess we just have to quietly keep
working away at it
well those are projects that we're
working on with partners for goal
district
okay any other commentary
tracy um
thanks richard and thank you kent and
rebecca for the work you've done here
and i guess you you have identified
quite a number of
real pinch points in in our community
and ones that we need to take very
seriously
but there's no getting away from the
fact that
retail is hard work it's been hard work
for a long time
and
there's a lot more competition than
there ever ever was
and i know
in the past
the competition was the person beside
you or the person on the other side of
the street but now the competition is
the person on the other side of the
world and
and
staying
ahead of that challenge is is a is a
real challenge
go retail was really an effort to
to try and
combat that and
and it had good points and then it's
sort of tapered off a bit
uh and it sounds like there's a
will to to look at reviving that
and look i think that's an opportunity
for council to be some sort of
facilitator there then
that's great
i think we should be right into that
space
however the council can't do it for
everyone there has to be a real
willingness from the majority of
retailers to buy into something like
that uh for it to be successful
people want to come and um
and shop in a place where there is
activity where there's vibrancy and and
gore's got all the opportunities for
that
it's just about pulling it together and
and as i say if if council can be a
conduit fantastic and i'll be all on for
that
but but re don't let me underestimate
the what i said before retail is hard
work
okay
thank you worship um yeah i think uh
probably the
detail there indicates where we are and
we use it as a reference um i do agree
initiatives have to be driven you know
from community um we can push it along
but we do need to have that um
have that drive from the actual um
business community particularly in that
business environment there uh and we are
happy to assist and and look at the
projects um
and i think kirk street you know we've
discussed that in relation to some of
our plans and
um
some of the changes that were made there
and there was some real positives come
out of that obviously some negatives but
some real positives around business and
usage of the street so
uh food for thought um
there's no more commentary there
mr g thank you sorry hi rebecca and kent
um i just wanted to highlight um some
really encouraging figures around the
potential gateway employers
at 80 percent
and
people who would consider hiring people
with disabilities as well at 46 that's
really really encouraging from a closing
the gaps perspective because they would
all meet funding criteria as well
so very encouraging
yeah most people were very
okay if there's no further discussion
i'll just seek someone to move that
survey report is received uh councillor
grant and seconded
uh councillor reed
all those in favor
thank you
okay
thank you
uh rebecca and kent and i believe you're
going to be staying online for our next
agenda
oh rebecca's
okay no thanks guys
uh okay and we
on to artist six which
is obviously uh positioning of gore um
it's been a lot of work
through various groups and workshops and
um both internally externally and um
around the area relating to the brown
cow uh round trout
campground cow i was gonna say brown
brown trout capital of the world
um black and white cows actually
brown trout capital of the world and
obviously looking um at positioning of
gore
in relation to that so we've got some
documentation there and obviously a
report from our consultants
um relating to that and you're going to
lead the discussion there okay so just
some background this is um one of the
first things that this committee asked
for uh when i
turned up in this position
and
we
got a small group of
uh staff so sonya and myself and um
councillor mcphail and councillor dixon
and amir tracy
to try and work out how we might do this
and great south um came to
the party as around around funding this
piece of work which was fantastic and
they definitely see the need
for us to understand the positioning
as gore as the brown trout capital of
the world and the work that rebecca did
in some of the research clearly showed
that there was a lot of articles even
dating back to the 1970s
so
i think the
the outcome of the report is very much
we are in a position to claim that there
is legitimacy around that
uh
and in talking to mark fruit who's the
new rgm for the tourism space at great
south and mark's been around the
industry a long time uh
in the rto space but also working within
new zealand and he was talking to me
about the fact that
tourism new zealand their
promotional strategy includes high-end
and this market is definitely seen as
high-end and he saw a real opportunity
there for gore if we can actually get
the positioning right
uh and to put ourselves out there and i
think also it was about the fact that we
need to claim that positioning because
if we don't we're going to lose it to
someone else
so in the report there on page 54 it
clearly outlines what the unique aspects
are
that
contribute to the
positioning and it also outlines the
challenges
that we're faced with and how do we
actually navigate those into the future
so i'm going to just hand over to
rebecca because rebecca was the person
that wrote this report and
alongside with kent who i think did some
of the interviews
and we tried to
give rebecca a cross-section of the
industry so
not just fishing guides but people that
we knew were
fly fishermen or women that
were in this district but also did that
worldwide and across new zealand because
they were in one of the better positions
to be able to say how we actually stack
up as an experience
so
we took quite a wide approach to it so
rebecca do you want to give a bit of an
overview
okay
thanks rebecca and kent
for that uh is there any other
commentary prior to opening it up to
okay just um before we uh i open it up
for discussion uh obviously we've got a
fairly good deep source document
document
here for those i'm fairly sure
some of us have seen it and been through
it through the draft stages a lot of
information a lot of content content in
it
and it's probably written through a time
when we get to the point today where we
look at it we've got a global situation
and an economic situation which we see
around town and various things changing
um
the strategy that's indicated there is
through i believe a five-year
five-year life of the strategy
so the decisions or the the projects we
look at
we are looking out at a reasonably long
window um around working forward
um
and it's tied to a number of other
different factors including river
quality and
and um
you know
the basis of that so
um i thank these guys for the content
and the report that's um in-depth
there's not much that hasn't been
scratched at or evoked or
brought to the surface
which is good and i now open it up to
the councillors for discussion i think
we are looking at trying to
go through
uh the actions required and whether we
agree or disagree uh the lists are quite
comprehensive there and where we trying
to go forward on so
uh i welcome the counselor's comments
uh thanks mr chair and thanks rebecca
and kent it certainly is a fulsome
report and some fascinating stuff in
there and some some really big potential
for
for this community uh going forward um
just a couple of questions and
and i'm just not sure where this sits
connection with the runanga i know we've
had a runanga person
involved on the on the
project
but
is that being considered by the runaway
do we know
um i'm just i'm interested i know trout
are not
natives at all but um i know that
zethonui have got a particular focus on
the life in the river and and i'm just
keen to get a sense of what their
thoughts are
on this whole process
um i think that
the message through the process was that
brown trout are not a native fish
so that's the first point for them
and their
big interest would be in the quality
water quality
aside of this project
i think it's a very comprehensive report
thank you it's actually quite a bit
there to digest
[Music]
i think we can only go forward with it
and do the best that we can but i do
take your point about the comments about
the loss of the mayfair rise
and i often wonder if that's not down to
the loss of the willows because i do
know that mayfly hatch and eddies and
backs back parts of the river then they
straightaway head to the trees that used
to be the willows
and the grasses on the riverbank to
actually mate because they have a very
short lifespan
so
you know
what are we looking at on the river
less willows
and environment south and saying that um
you know they're going to be looking at
flood protection and the
river has straightened the water flows
much more quickly
on the whole and there is no cover and
no willow
areas and even if they were planted in
groupings down the river maybe that
would help improve the quality
because
while the water quality from nitrates
and things is another story
they still have somewhere to breed and
as i say they have a very short breeding
cycle so
i don't know how you change that but i
think it does need to be looked at
glenis
thank you mr chair um just adding on to
that i know that fish really needs shade
and so
um there's not a lot of shade left on
the rivers either with the willows
coming out so
that could be something that we can look
at i know there is a matara water
catchment group my tower river water
catchment group
and they're doing a lot of work doing
some riparian plantings along the river
which might be
quite
quite helpful
but i really um
yes it is a great report and i really
support um it's moving on with this and
promoting it because i think that is a
position that gore can take and
and um it can add to a
to a big bundle of things that gore can
do well
dear mr we have you know for a long time
claimed the brownshout capital of the
world title
um
and and i guess if we're serious about
that then we need to put some
you know meat around the bones of what
what that looks like i'm i'm just not
sure in my mind what the next steps are
in terms of
and i'll be keen
from either rebecca or kendall or anne
just
what do you see as
the obvious logical next steps for the
council to take
and
yeah and i'm also
interested in
you know
who is interested in the dollars just
wonder what the dollars are likely to
look like
by going down this track
um
but i
creating your stories creating your
values and ensuring you've got a shared
vision at the end and then an achieved
look
for the positioning of water as brown
chapters of the world is really
important because then that will start
performing your next steps and i would
say a very critical step after that is
to
get a dedicated website developed
and this really will ensure that it
cements your position
positioning is
the brown charcoal knowledge
credibility um
website and it will also inform anything
one of the else i think was looking
around interpretation panels within your
book designer statue and kind of linking
up to the motorway center and into the
river and other places as well and so
when you have that brand you'll be able
to feed
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah
okay
thanks
yeah thanks for that tracy just um
uh obviously a couple a couple of things
that drop out of that is obviously in
relation to
um
because there is a 11 key tasks there
and i think that it's
there's probably a phased
a couple of phases to to that
uh and whether there's any glaring ones
in there that and there's probably
financial issues or
a tag on some of those
which we would have to present through
to council anyway any recommendation
around that
um
the
you know whether it's worth discussing
the the
building of a viewing platform or
anything like that in this forum or
whether the concept goes through uh or
is it part of a
later stage phase we take some of the
low-hanging fruit to start off
uh and i'd also be interested obviously
they've indicated in regards to the
website um
is that something that we need to be
discussing with their you know with
their specialist or comms communication
marketing
um
because there's a number of uh tasks
there so i'd be interested to see if
there's any discussion on that
uh neville are you
thanks mr
i've just got a
and one of those 11 those 11 key tasks
there's no
nothing mentioned about
cooperation with ewey or
with the matera
liaison group
they may have ideas that we probably
that wouldn't may enhance
the air cooperation with them
so i think you know that should be one
of the key tasks and i agree that um his
story of the those 11 key tasks there
should be
as there is a five-year strategic plan
set aside that we set aside
uh small steps first and i think i like
the idea of uh telling you a story
within the trout
statue
and that would be easily done their
communications
i think that's also getting out there
pretty quickly
so
i'd like to see that we
have collaboration with our local eoi
and also the liaison group
if i may um just just be able to help
here we are actually already working on
an interpretation panel for the trout
stature that's a project we're doing in
conjunction with
the gore lions club
um so that will be hopefully rolled out
in time for their um anniversary next
year
thanks for that sonja
um
just in regard to obviously ue
partnership um that we did with joe
have um through the renault um that she
had gone through the drafts and has been
partied to the document that has been
produced to to here today but obviously
that that partnership doesn't end at the
production of this it will continue on
so but the material liaison definitely
um we have we
probably have
heads yeah we'd have to review that
uh so there's obviously a recommendation
at the end here
in regard to are we
sort of
heading towards that we endorse
the whole project or
is there anything in here that
perhaps needs to be thinned out or taken
out at this time
or is it still open for discussion do we
i think that's probably what the group's
looking for would that be correct
i think you have to keep in mind that
this project can only go forward and be
successful if it's resourced financially
and
it's over five years it's not something
that's going to happen tomorrow but
actually it's the need to put the right
things in place up front and in talking
with great south like
mark and i already have some of the
contacts with fly fishing over 30 years
so there's some things that i can work
with him to put in place straight away
but we don't have that robust repository
of all of the information around this
that
a fly fishing audience across the world
will be looking for
and i guess i'm i'm definitely in the
space that this should be an independent
standalone website and i would give you
the example of tussock country if we put
all of that tacit country information
into a gore and zed
it actually would overwhelm
all the other beautiful things that gore
has so it's trying to find the balance
in there but if it's not resourced by
council that's not actually going to be
a possibility
do we have any idea of the budget that
we would need i mean i would i would
definitely support developing a brand
and doing interpretation panels
and a website
in the staff just the beginning and then
have a strategic plan with a budget
for the next five years
um worked
out through the committee
communications general manager
um for developing the brand
um you're possibly looking at about
fifteen hundred two thousand dollars
a standalone website um probably between
ten to fifteen thousand dollars
we are i think i think a digital
presence is really important for our um
positioning and we are in a really good
place right now where we are revamping
the gore nz website and having quite a
lot of content
developed and built in there around the
brown trout fishing so there'll be a
number of pages which will be dedicated
to
that it obviously uh begs the question
that we aren't uh are we doubling up on
some of the if there's orange stuff in
existence
that perhaps we should be making sure
part of the phase with this
has been collected into that um on to
that process
um
we'll have obviously got do
you know
uh nick
thanks as the chairperson just the other
thing is like the water quality is
massive for me
like the first thing you do is google
water quality first and you come up it
says e coli and unswimable
so anyone who's going to look at that
from overseas are going to go well why
go fishing there when you can't you
can't eat it you got to release it if
you do intend on doing that so there's a
lot of work to be done with water
quality i know a lot of anglers who
fished the matilda river now go further
abroad because the waters are cleaner
i guess from my perspective we've got to
secure the brown trout capital of the
world brand and to do that we're going
to develop a brand
um
and i'm just
i'm i guess i'm just unclear in my own
mind just what the physical steps are
not so much about developing the brand
but actually
using that brand once we we've developed
it but that doesn't have to happen
overnight
doesn't have to happen tonight as long
as we've got a clear intent that we want
to be the brown trout capital of new
zealand and we want to take steps or
ground drought capital of the world and
we want to take the appropriate steps to
make that happen in
the quickest way possible in the most
affordable way possible
and and i think that oh yeah i'll leave
it at that
okay so uh thank you tracy um we've
obviously
an agreeance that there is um there is a
development project here that which
would we will obviously go through
motion but
um are we looking at
whether we put this back
to the community strategy group to give
us the phases of
like obviously support um or
see if i've got a feeling that we
endorse what we've got here but we're
looking at how a phased approach plus we
probably need some dollar value
um to either have it presented
yeah mr chairman if i can help the
the meeting um
it strikes me that what you the next
phase of this is for as you said
casting our nets across the um action
plan and allocating some more detailed
steps and some costings but inevitably
this is going to come up against other
visitor related investments that the
council's got to grapple with and i'm
referring to the likes of tussock
country which is supportive of the
country music capital of new zealand
and of course our arts and heritage
offering so and as elected members
you you know that there's a finite pool
of resource
so it may well be that the best approach
would be for the staff to come back with
a refined report with some suggestions
but bring that to the full council so
all the members can then
wrestle with how does this stack up
against some of those other high
priorities that we have in that broader
visitor attraction area
so um good good point steve i'm just not
sure you're allowed to cast your net
into the river to catch trout but runs
just wondering on
timing on that because we do need to
make
you know make haste i think
you worship you tell us when you want to
see it and we'll deliver it
um yeah yesterday um
okay like
yeah obviously um
thank you steve for that
with that
phased approach we looked at getting a
refined report to come back to full
council as soon as possible
um
with indication on costing but i think
within the phased
approach and obviously we'll put it to
the vote that um we have the steps those
initial steps that are going to be
carried out
uh
we obviously uh looking at those 11 key
tasks
that are in there
but the ones that actually need to be
phased in
around the commentary
that we've received um establishing and
retaining that brand and seeing how that
um
how that works or how that is
established will probably have to be
included in that
in that phased approach
um
just looking at the recommendation there
that the port report we received the
committee endorsed the brown trout
promotional strategy which
isn't i'll put that to the vote that's
indicating
do we need to indicate which projects or
projects we need anymore
project or projects
or do we why do we actually ask for the
phased
report to include that for full council
that we've endorsed this report and then
we're not removing anything from it
at present and that will be put to full
council for discussions
not anticipate when it comes to full
council we'll have that information
you're talking about
steve and lining it up against some of
the other
big
promotional things that are going on at
the same time
through you mr chairman there that's
correct so i think the recommendation
and the third prong of that would be
not that you prioritize projects unless
you want to now but that you uh seek
a further report to the full council by
staff
[Music]
offering up
a pathway of
suggested
action points and projects to
complete with
funding
allocation suggestions
and that this be placed in context with
the council's current and proposed
commitments to other
attraction
um sectors
we get all that recommendation
um
yeah because obviously we've uh
we've got some tasks on there that
haven't
like if we were going to investigate the
opportunity to build a
platform there's obviously some
substantial
costings and and
you know matters that need to be
discussed on that and that would be
clearly way down their phase
or if at all would be part of that but
there's clearly some that would be well
stacked up in the in the phase process
would that the expectations of the
committee
clearness
thank you mr chair i don't see that this
should become a choice between some of
these other projects and this project i
see that it should be considered on its
merit because it does bring in a lot of
income
into the town i know these fishermen
come in here and they do spend a lot of
money and they do buy houses in town so
i don't see it to be
a choice i just think it needs to be
looked at on its own merit
thank you venice
i think we don't have to change too much
on the in the recommendation and like
the recommendations say is that the
committee endorsed the brown trout
promotional strategy
and that the committee we just changed
and that
staff indicate which projects or
projects they would like to see advanced
and first order and resources and budget
identified and developed bring that
forward to council at the next meeting
would that be
an easy way around it
yeah
steve
and i disagree with with glennis and
saying that this is not about making
choices look i think that um you know
for example tussock country and trout
trout
capital of the world program
but there's not a choice between one or
the other they're both going to happen
it's about the timing and just how we
progress those and in my mind anyway
there's both of them are well worth
the effort and there'll be other
projects that'll fit in there too but we
can't do everything at the same time and
we've just got to make sure that we've
got um
our you know bases covered and doing the
important thing and certainly from my
perspective the important thing in this
particular subject is about securing the
brand
and then we can use then we can work out
whatever platform there's going to be to
promote that brand
okay thank you tracy so we've obviously
got
uh the recommendation there we
as the general feeling is that we
endorse
uh the content of what's here we're not
going to separate
anything out at prison it goes back to
the
obviously staff the committee's
indicated the content of the report
stands and that they will come back to
us with phase
phase and budget and resources around
the facilitation of um early stage
development obviously in regard to brand
and
um securing so
i think we have that and
if someone would like to
move that recommendation
uh neville
and seconded by glennis all those in
favor
all right
thank you
um
could i just like to add it's a great
piece of work and well done everybody
yeah i think
i think that goes uh
goes from everyone here to to ken and
rebecca there's a huge amount of efforts
gone into that
report and as i've said previously the
standard of reports that we receive
from the group is um it's always of a
high standard and
plenty of content for us to examine
so thank you for that thank you
councillors uh we'll move on to the
next item uh are these guys going to
head away
thanks for joining the meeting
we are moving to just the transitions
um just transitions we've got a um
report from bobby brown and i think
you're going to just talk us
thank you talk talk us through so ann's
going to take us through us
so on the agenda is the july report
from just transitions from bobby brown
and bobby is the
lead for this project
i'm not going to go through the report
in detail but just remind you that just
transitions as a project
lead is actually mb and the purpose is
for helping southland build its economic
and environmental and social resilience
beyond um
the proposed closure of
new zealand's aluminium smelters so ty
our council actually has
a significant put a significant amount
of time into this
just transition process because there is
16 work streams
and med chat tracy is the chair of the
oversight
and our chief executive is the chair of
the
housing
uh work stream yeah just just a
small correction i'm not the chair i'm a
member of the right of the oversight
committee so here's a good understanding
of what's happening at that level
and there's other
other work streams beyond 2025
so
that is very much around
the redevelopment of the destination
management strategy that was put in
place three years ago but with the
change of environment
that's been reviewed
so i'm sitting on that oversight group
and also attending all of those
workshops and
developing up their destination
management strategy
so if you have any questions maybe
between the chief executive tracy and
myself
you may be able to answer them
thanks
for that
and um
i've obviously been partied to some of
the briefings from
um bobby anyway so and i think
worship was there
um
i'd open it up to the floor to ask any
questions in relation to the content of
that
dennis
thank you mr i just have one question um
the smelter has changed its plan i i
believe and it's now going to remain
open
um
it's not going to affect this in any way
we'll still
continue
with this transition yeah so the
work process is still going to continue
through and
there's been reassurance that that will
complete the process some more extremes
are in a phase that they're completing
their strategy and it's going to
wellington for consideration which fills
into the next budget round
other pieces of work are just in the
starting phase so if all the streams are
at different stages
certainly
certainly the
situation with the smelter uh is
it it's changed from two years ago when
the announcement was made um but it's
still pretty fluid and there's a whole
lot of other options
um that are sort of coming in from their
field in terms of you know what can be
what the electricity can be used for and
just how much electricity is required
and whatever so so there's a there's a
whole lot of options with regard to the
to this to the smelter with you know
all that beside there's a huge job to be
done um by rio in terms of remediation
uh and
from
everything that i read they're getting
on and doing that but it's um it's not
something that's going to happen
in a year or two years it's it's quite a
long process
so
there's going to be some uncertainty for
for quite some time i think
and certainly the just transition
process is uh one that's been set up
we're only the second
uh just transition process ever to be uh
assembled in new zealand first one was
in taranaki and and it's still working
through a whole lot of a lot of
challenges on its own but from a local
government perspective that developing
the beyond 2025
program has probably been the biggest
focus for for a local government um
we're of course we're involved in a
whole lot of other bits and pieces but
but just the work that bobby's pulling
together is um is substantial
uh and it is going to give us a really
good platform i think to um
to spring forward
thanks for that um tracy um
any other questions discussion in
regards to the document obviously
there's um
a lot of a lot of it's in the uh
i know work stream wise as reliance it
is reliant on other work streams to be
completed so that they can move forward
and i think this is in here it indicates
just trying to remember how many 16
different work streams i think we're in
number six at the moment seven seven of
the 16 work work streams um don't have
set deliverables or approaches as yet so
um you know there's obviously a lot of
work still still to go on
um through that and through to 2025 so
but um if there's no other discussion or
if i could just have someone move that
the report has
received
councillor grant and second council reid
thank you
and now we move on to
uh sorry i'll do all those in favor
all right thank you
we move on to our community strategy
progress to date presentation which our
community strategy manager and will be
um running us through so
i think you've got powerpoint
yep
so community strategy update um
i might just pass these around because
you remember
so
this document came from a strategy for
growth which we went through a process
and finalised at the end of last year
you established the community strategy
position
will be two years ago in november
kylie came into the team one year ago
and mark came around the same time
in november but doing
the youth council and
the welcoming community space and then
moved into
closing the gaps so the team's actually
two full-time equivalent people even
though there's three of us
so i just wanted to give you an update
where we're at with the good district
identity work you'll remember that we
had a half day
workshop we developed up
all of this information the social image
the personality the icons
a lot of that work it's been put on hold
partly after in discussion with steve
we talked about the fact that mariaway
is coming and it's got a lot of the
stories so we don't want to duplicate um
we want to use the resources of what is
actually already happening in the
organisation
and then working with sonia
and caitlin on their work that they're
doing with
the website we've taken across some of
those stories we defined that day so
you'll start to see a shift and lining
up to what we agreed on when we had that
workshop
so these were three
key components and bring kit you may
remember we talked about that day that
it was a really need for brain kit which
actually puts all of your images and ips
in one place so sonya and i've worked on
that and it's up and established and
when the website goes live that will be
available
more for the public
so we've also done three days of
photoshoot now part of that was
initiated through our closing the gaps
work because we needed
images of young people
and
you'll see some of those images starting
to come through in the website material
but we also have chris mclennan who's
world renowned but is originally from
gore came here and he did that three
days for us
and we took him to a lot of locations
that are not what i'd call standard
places that people in gore actually
think about and he was blown away by
some of those even though he knew the
district
so at some point we would like to get
him back again to do more of
just basically presenting us in a
different way in a different light
sony do you want to give an update on
the a website
um no you're doing a good job but just
um if anyone wanted to have a look at
the brain kit it is live and we just
haven't publicized it as ann said until
we do go live it's just
images.gorionz.com
so you're more than welcome to jump on
there and have a look
so the sector plans which is on the
document there the welcome plan you've
seen and approved an implementation is
underway and actually just today
mark and i received all the design
material so it gives us a professional
look like we have for ready for living
and closing the gaps which is very cool
so that will be
the image and the look and feel going
forward so we're in the phase of
developing the welcome plan and the
intention is that like sorry the welcome
pack and the intention is that will be
rolled out in september we actually have
a working group of community people that
have come together and they've done
quite a bit of that work which i was
incredibly grateful because mark has
been out of the equation for the last
six to eight weeks
and
with their help and and mark picking it
up again this week we're almost there
aren't we which is really awesome
the event plan was done over a year ago
and um
sony and i had a discussion about it
because there was the intention to
report back now but actually it didn't
make sense to do that because of the
covet environment and a lot of things
haven't been able to happen
because of covert in this space so next
year you will get a report back on that
trails feasibility was done some time
ago i think it was like maybe 2017. does
it sound right
it's more than five years and bits and
pieces of that trails feasibility have
been picked up by the trails group that
exists in war
ready for living
the
we're making huge progress here i'm with
the strategy document for ready for
living and our intention is to actually
start the review process in november we
had a really positive meeting with the
working group a couple of weeks ago and
we went through and
probably the most the biggest
outstanding issue is really around
i suppose you could call it the housing
space of elderly people and how could we
do that differently in gore and i guess
because the environment's shifting so
much there's now a gap in the market
between people being in their house
to going to rest home care and so if you
went back
five plus years people would have been
moving to a rest home here and they
would still be a lot more able than they
potentially are now but people are still
looking for some space that actually
doesn't exist here at the moment
so there's a lot of um a conversation i
had with sharon adler um she actually
wasn't it's been to europe and she'll
will come and talk to us at some point
about this
but was looking at really innovative
spaces and she also talked about
different parts of new zealand that are
picking up pieces within that so we're
probably just going to park that as we
move into the renew view of the strategy
and there will be something that will
then have to have some focus
uh labor force we're currently working
on this piece of work right now so the
the latest discussions of not with 91
businesses and the report you received
today helps to inform that piece of work
but in southland at the moment you've
got the regional labor force group
you've got a work stream and just
transitions and you've got ourselves
with closing the gaps you've got
hokunuikunu doing some some pieces
you've got the rananga doing some pieces
um
i'm sure i'm missing one or two so mark
and i have been trying to coordinate
um the conversation with all of those
people to get a position of where is
gore at and what are the real things
that we need on the ground here
so that piece of work hopefully will
come to you at the next committee
meeting
youth council mark do you want to
comment
yes
um
yes this is a new development this year
um so um nick and myself have worked
with the council to establish groups
that oversee events
uh communications and projects and that
gives them that sense or that increased
sense of responsibility in making things
happen for in the community and we've
also had a number of guest speakers
uh come on a regular basis to share
their knowledge and skills with the
youth counselors as well and that's been
really well received including the mayor
himself
and fundraising we've recently raised
200 dollars for picture day um in
support of mental health awareness and
that involved the
members undertaking days
from ice baths to um ice bucket
challenges to
spicy nasty food um eating competitions
to
uh just wearing their pajamas to school
as well so um fair play to them they did
really well
uh yes coming up um so big news uh we'll
be having the
first youth awards for a couple of years
on the 10th of december this year and
we're hoping that uh hayden jones will
be able to come along and be the guest
speaker at that event there's going to
be a country theme
and we're in
encouraging people to come along dressed
accordingly as well and have a bit of
fun on the night with it
the skatepark redevelopment um we're
hoping is going to go ahead in the next
three to four months
we've been in discussion with keith
mcrobbie parks and rec manager
to um through the youth council to
improve what we currently have at the
skate park in terms of fencing uh this
discussion around a climbing wall um
although that hasn't been confirmed yet
and that will vastly improve that um
space for youth
um the frisbee golf course as well again
we're in discussion with keith and a
number of other stakeholders in the area
some who were involved with the dolma
park frisbee um
frisbee golf course
and there's a lot of enthusiasm there to
set something up in hamilton park
as a more accessible course
for families to go along and have a bit
of fun with their children
thank you
thanks mark
a good dataset
we had some initial conversations with
great south about this but i've put that
discussion on hold because within some
of the work streams and just transitions
data sets is coming up so i want to see
what the outcome of that is first before
we look to progress this
um
on the document you'll see there these
are all sectors that we said we would
liaise with and
you had suggested probably the uh the
one
i might this to our team community
strategy hasn't really touched baseballs
would be water all of the others we've
definitely having conversations with the
intention is that there will be some
workshops with
in the sectors when we look to redevelop
the community
strategy going forward
so thriving southland have a regular
liaison um met with
sharon
sandra sorry this week and she told me
that there's three more groups in ghoul
district been established in catchment
groups and there will be another
coordinator coming on into our district
for those three
we're working on a couple of projects
together with
ann weber that are in the food and fibre
sector to see what we can get going
sandra is actually a real key for us
because when we're trying to connect
with the right people in the rural
community she actually knows a lot of
them and
and we can ask her different things and
she'll connect me up with people that
are interested in a subject
etc so
really valuable and
been really helpful for us to get the
courses
out into the rural sector so pretty
grateful for her
um input regularly catching up with
hakane rananga and joe particularly joe
and joe is sitting on several of our
groups but mark's worked a lot with
ricky and then also with matu so
um i think you know there's not many
weeks go by when we're not talking to
them
in this area the community hub the
feasibility is underway so this is the
cnt
building and the potential relocation of
that
but it's interesting in the health
locality space there needs to be a
conversation just about what that might
look like and what the needs in that hub
so having to connect that up very
shortly
steve i don't know if do you want to
comment on any of the others here
um
the town and country one that's really
just been liaison because they're
looking to actually redevelop that
and you're looking to obtain some
funding because there's a significant
estimate our event space at the moment
thanks steve
safe in the south all of these things
have been coming up in our age friendly
discussion and also in the work with
neighborhood
support
loneliness definitely has got more on
our radar since covert and people
you know being in the home environment
and not venturing out so much and outer
abuse we did try to apply for some
government funding for elder abuse but
weren't successful but through that we
have established some quite strong
connections with
different government agencies in
wellington so we're sort of we will
pursue that
neighborhood support we're working with
it i already mentioned today how often
this is actually sits within the council
environment
um cnt is the lead on this and are
working closely with
ourselves and also police so these are
only a few of the points that i've put
in here but they're starting to make
inroads and we've been having
discussions about how do we get
neighbour support into the rural
community
health the big one on there is the
locality networks and i've only really
just joined that conversation in the
last two weeks i had a few hours in
dunedin with well south in
stuart barson who is leading that
coordination um
for the hokunui
locality network
so yeah that's probably the big one
in that space
and of course there is a lot of liaison
that kylie's doing as well for
in the aged space
all of these we have strong
relationships with now um when we
started we couldn't have said that so
those relationships are either held by
kylie or mark or myself
education the main areas we're working
closely is reap sit and secondary they
haven't done so much in the primary or
early childhood international students
we've had discussions with both our high
schools here
uh
about
the covert environment and how we move
out of that um and in to attracting
students and i know that discussion when
i met with sit yesterday
the international students came up as
well
community directory
so this is a piece of work that's been
done by the cnt team with cali young
leading so they're slowly building this
directory which is online
which has actually been really
really needed
in our community so the focus of it is
on
can the community providers
hakanuihuno the evaluation report has
been completed
and the hanoi will be presenting that to
stakeholders in september um mark and i
and colley are regularly in liaison with
lisa and we do actually sit on one or
two
groups together
ready for living i don't think there's
anything on there that
you don't know about
probably the one that i would say is the
strengthening program that kylie runs
has been really successful and there is
demand for us to put two more of those
in place but that is actually a really
real big challenge for us because
we've got other priorities i guess so
we're really looking to see if there's
another way of doing it can we get
someone else to take them and where
could those courses actually be held and
to date we haven't actually been able to
resolve that but it's definitely on our
radar
so the future um
focus is really going to be getting
funding again because kylie's position
is funded through to the end of june and
we really need that to continue because
we've made huge inroads in the last 12
months
so we will be
pitching to ph vickery trust again
we do a six month free report kylie and
i and our intention is to go to
christchurch and catch up with them
they're really happy with the
relationship with council
it's just how does that look so i don't
want us to be in the position that um
we don't know whether we've got funding
and we really lose kylie because of that
so we're going to start that process
before christmas
college just started the age friendly
business
15 was it kylie businesses this last
week that you've been to
and the mayor had asked us
that we
make sure our own organisation and our
teams are age friendly so she's doing a
round of meetings with individual teams
at the moment and working through that
process so our intention is to review
start the process of reviewing the
strategy we're looking to start with
some workshops we're just still
discussing
what the best process will be we're
thinking because we actually when the
strategy was done a few years ago as a
pilot it was probably more driven by
agency
and we're wanting to actually hear from
the community this time
so we intend to do some smaller meetings
and then take the information to the
agencies to test it
youth hub uh the youth hub
came
onto the strategy document from
the growth strategy we have a question
whether that's actually needed um and or
because there are two or three providers
that are actually doing a lot of good
work
and the piece that seems to be missing
when we talk to people who are working
the spaces it doesn't seem to be a
collaborative meeting which was a bit
like when we started in the workforce
space and people didn't actually get
together to understand whatever each
other are doing so that's where we're
going to start
just to try and get an understanding of
what's actually needed
so these were the housing things that
were on there um an update from kayanga
aura as they've just met with them on
friday in dunedin
they've got a plan they are just
assessing
the various mix of housing so whether
it's one bedroom two bedroom four
bedroom six bedroom uh it looks like 19
properties at the moment
uh they said that the next thing that we
will see is demolition on site
steve do you want to comment because
you're the chair of housing
yeah
as uh anna said i'm chair of a housing
forum
group which is part of the just
transitions
and it's quite interesting that
this council is
quite hands-on with housing
through our mata ridge joint venture
development compared to other councils
where
there has been
pretty much left to the market place i
suppose but invercargill are heavily
invested in
trying to work out what its housing
needs are
and so hence we've actually commissioned
a body of work about looking at what are
the southland housing needs
in the region
and there are
requests for
specific
data to be reduced coming from
invercargill and southland less so from
us but we're very still like we're
invested in
the the project um and that is hoped to
then give us a good platform to work
from and i'm certainly keen as chair to
see that we get a pilot project out of
this too because
i think housing is
the way we provide housing traditionally
the needs of different members of the
community
differ
and i think the um the barriers to
accessing quality housing are such that
it demands probably a fresh approach so
we're hopeful that we can develop a
pilot project too
by the end of their time
of actually submitting a report so that
it can be a live example
and there's been some good examples
already given particularly we had a
presentation from
fiordland
where there's been
some quite
unique approaches taken to
how you for example you treat land in a
project and take some of the high cost
out of that
um so that's a bit of a sort of a quick
fire summary of where we are
sonia's team are doing a great job of
that
marketing plan um
we talked about a marketing plan but
because of the identity work
and these areas still need to be further
developed from a product perspective
before we do that marketing work and
also that is a resourcing issue as well
maruwai i think you're all up to speed
with what's happening there and i
believe there's a report coming
yes miroi the tenders are being
solicited as we speak
and it's hoped that a report on those
tenders will be submitted to the council
late
in september very early october
thanks steve
a labor force i don't think i need to go
over this because i think we've pretty
much covered it all off but we've signed
the contract the next step is to
actually
get the person in place again for which
is a fixed term contract through the end
of june next year
um regional business partner network is
a program that's run through
great south and ben lewis heads there so
mark and i work regularly with ben on
what needs to come to gore and they
actually come into the offices here to
meet with businesses
um
i think we've had we've discussed with
them about some of the challenges of
regional business because it partners
network because there's a lot of things
on offer and if we really need to break
it down because otherwise it's quite
confusing of how people engage with it
but that will continue on in the next
over the next year
i'm calling the same thing they are
coming to gore and they have a
interesting program that's just started
an avocado called make it and so it's
really business business people or
individuals that have ideas about a
product and we're looking at the
possibility that that makeup course
could be run out of sit
next year here and go which would be
awesome because there's quite a few
people that would be interested in that
chamber
mark and i try and get along to the
chamber meetings when they're in gore
just you know it helps with the liaison
but also they've been involved in the
newcomers leadership program and we did
have some issues trying to get funding
for that so they've picked up the mentor
because we needed a central organisation
for all of southland doing it as
individual councils wasn't working
in the business networking space we have
a business facebook page which we're
really using just to push out the events
that are happening
and i guess one of the things that we're
wanting to do is establish a newsletter
to all the people that are now on our
database to keep them informed of the
things that are available and coming
because that seems to be the challenge
for us is actually getting all that
information out to people
trump project we've talked about today
digital connectivity there is a piece of
work that's been done
and commissioned through great south and
we're expecting to receive that piece of
work shortly
we've sort of covered off just
transitions
immigration mark is the person that
tends to liaise on the immigration front
there was quite a bit of work in the
space when we're in covert and when
there was a lot of uncertainty for our
migrant community so mark's role is
actually connecting
people to the right people
so we're looking to revise the strategy
we're looking at maybe it's five uh
workshops
um in their communities and then that
list of sectors and that list of sectors
is probably not complete
which would also inform the community
outcomes for the ltp
the long-term plan
we would propose to start this work
early next year and through to june
um
i guess the thing i'm really conscious
of is we don't want to be going to the
community
endlessly because then they get fatigue
of consultation and conversation and i'm
also very aware there's other things
going on with other agencies so we are
in discussion with some of those other
agencies if they are going to be going
to the community where are the
opportunities for us to work together
to get because we're all looking for
similar types of information
so
that's a bit of a work in progress for
going forward
so that's it
got any questions
it's not a question it's just a comment
to you kylie mark and who did i say
do you ever get time to sleep it's a
really it's a lot of work and it's a
really good direction for us to be going
in on it's it's quite impressive so
thank you for your work for your
leadership in all this area and and for
mark and kylie and sonya
and just a comment mark great work with
the youth council in conjunction with
nick
i like that leadership thing that's
great
and sonia the friday
thing that you're doing on facebook
so many of my friends have commented and
um they just love seeing
the old photos and you know yadda yadda
it's a long conversation but thank you
all it's good work thank you councillor
um i would also just like to thank
councillor grant because without you
nick i would have been sunk in the last
two months and i really really
appreciated jews putting your hand up
and sending me an email saying i can
pick up youth council so thank you so
much for that because it meant we didn't
lose any momentum
and
having mark giving us some direction
from a distance was also good so we're
actually in a really good place because
i was worried we were not going to be so
we couldn't have done that without you
thank you
any
other questions for
and or progress um it is a busy
busy platform and a busy place
um when you actually see it all laid out
like that you realize the amount of
amount of input and
networking and engagement and projects
that are flowing through the the
community strategies uh office and i am
aware of that from some of my in-depth
discussions with and
at various times but um i think it's a
good report and it's good to keep us
updated
um some of them are quite open-ended
projects too that go on for a long time
and you can't get that closure and just
produce the the result all one one hit
you know they're quite fluid and they um
change direction at certain stages and
you know the natural conclusion uh
cannot be evident sometimes but uh
thanks to work from the team
just someone might recommend that that
report is received
councillor eden secretary council dixon
and um
all in favor
and once again thanks um that's the end
of the agenda unless there's anything
else that's
in there that which has been discussed
um thank you councillors for your time
today we've obviously had quite a long
day uh appreciate it we've gone through
a number of different things but um
there's nothing else i'll close the
meeting at that stage thank you